Apes together strong war for the Planet
of the Apes I'm probably going to end up
getting the spoilers pretty quick so let
me get my spoiler free version of this
review out right at the top here short
version
spoiler free it is good it is very good
it is a great conclusion to this trilogy
of films that was rise dawn and now war
and it's just it wraps everything up
really well Andy Serkis is amazing
visually it is stunning the character
work is great personally speaking I
think I like dawn a little bit better
part of that has to do with preferences
in terms of tone and the one thing that
I will caution people going in is the
marketing has been kind of miss selling
this and I think the title does as well
because both the name and the marketing
war for the plan of the aides implies a
much more visceral kind of action film
then this is actually delivering not to
say that there isn't some of that stuff
in there there is and I'll talk more
about that as I get into the spoiler end
of things but it does not make up the
bulk or the majority of the film so know
what you're getting into it is a bit
slower than the marketing is selling it
as so adjust your expectations based on
that but it is very very good
there's just for the free let's get
right into it first off man
that I love this trilogy I mean I love
this trilogy I loved rise when it came
out it knocked me just completely bowled
me over I didn't see it coming dawn just
took me places I'm like how can an arrow
to be this smart in terms of where it's
going and be fighting so many obvious
landmines and this last one I had a few
moments like that as well but because it
does have to bring more or less some
kind of conclusion to things it's not
quite as unpredictable on point for
point things as dawn of the Planet of
the Apes was so that's part of why I
liked all a little bit better the other
thing that I mentioned is tone which is
that the tone of dawn had a little bit
more Hope running through it now
ultimately that hope didn't pan out
because what you're hoping for is peace
between the humans and the Apes and
ultimately that's not what the film
delivers in the end but there is still
that threat of hope running through the
film this
one it's not about like the only thing
you're hoping for is just survival
forget peace and and I think that's one
of the things because it opens two years
later and I think I I had assumed that I
think a lot of folks it assumed that it
was going to open right after the end of
dawn because that's when the military
first showed up but instead they jump
ahead two years I think the reason to do
that is they need to skip past the point
where you would be thinking oh how is
the first encounter gonna go is the
military going to treat them as hostile
is there still hope for working this out
no no it's two years later fighting is
full-on
and we're going to open with a scene
that makes it incredibly clear war is on
and the crew you it is you're supposed
to be siding with because the other
thing would dawn was it was a bit more
look the humans are in this situation so
you understand where they're coming from
the Apes are in this situation you
understand where they're coming from
this is a case where it's a bit more
black and right very firmly you are
supposed to be on the H side in this
conflict and honestly you are the humans
are not particularly sympathetic
although in terms of talking about the
we I mean Woody Harrelson basically is
it there's like one other human that
gets highlighted and and you know has
some moments and that's nice but
basically everything is funneled through
Woody Harrelson specifically because all
the other characters are just soldiers
and they're sort of taken you know
you've seen one you've seen them all
these guys are following the command of
this guy so this guy's kind of the only
one who matters so in terms of Woody
Harrelson's portrayal I think he does I
think Woody Harrelson always does a good
job I can't remember ever seeing him
turn in a bad performance and he does
bring similarity get some moments to add
some depth to it but he is very clearly
the villain of this piece I suppose in a
way that Cobo was in the previous one
but I feel like you've got more of an
understanding of Koba than we get of
this guy just relative to each other
um and I do I think they might have
pushed him into out-and-out villainy a
little bit too far along not I'm not
sure I actually mean that I functionally
I think it was probably the smart thing
to do but I'd like there was a moment
during basically you sort of here's my
back
and here's my philosophy brandish'd
thing it was the point where he's like
this is a holy war and implying that
he's come up with this bizarre almost
religious basis for what he's doing in
that I don't know that certainly has a
step too far and I have a hard time
specifically articulating why but it
just seems like one step too many but
look he can be just fundamental on the
basis of human survival is paramount
over all things it doesn't have to cross
over into like this from borderline
religious fanaticism I don't think I
mean kids because the thing was they
didn't do anything with that I'm not
saying that there's no grounds to have
that as part of the character but I felt
like it was just there and like look how
crazy is because he believes that he is
on a holy mission to exterminate the
Apes I'm like yeah but why it just what
it went somewhere that it didn't
actually have any it didn't have
anything that it was going to do with
that but that aside his performance is
very good he is definitely the villain
of this piece but the star
unquestionably of the whole franchise
and this film specifically is without a
doubt Caesar
Andy Serkis holy crap okay first of all
the Apes look amazing I mean every time
one of these has come out I have said or
thought you know the eggs look amazing
and every time every new movie they look
better it's crazy how good these eggs
look but you know that's that kind of a
given technology movement moves forward
the stuff gets better but Andy Serkis
gives such an amazing performance and
just doing so little I mean he speaks
the most articulately that Caesar has
ever spoken in this film but that isn't
one what is amazing about the
performance like very early on there's a
moment where just another egg delivers
to him just news he doesn't want to hear
and his own really reaction is just this
exhale like it's not a big executive is
another thing it's just and I can't
recreate it properly but just everything
about the body language the pace the
tone of just an exhale tells you
everything it is so good and all the
other Apes are great Maurice was another
standout he was great we got a new way
introduced and this was interesting
because this could have really gone off
the rails he's just he just refers
himself as bad ape and he's interesting
for a lot of reasons part of which are
kind of intellectual and having to do
with the franchise of the whole and that
is the idea that it that the virus that
spread globally did impact other Apes
aside from Caesars community so it does
mean that other Apes possibly around the
entire world are all as smart as Caesar
and his and his family in his colony is
so that's a cool implication and just
the character of bad ape and he's very
much the inserted comedic relief
character and that can go really sour
but I think a the movie kind of needed
it because I guess that this is that
this is a heavy movie this thing is not
messing around I think it needed that
little bit of levity since it doesn't
have the same strength of a hope
narrative that the previous one had so
there's that but in addition that he is
legitimately funny and Steve Zahn plays
him and plays him great you just get so
much just again from literally is just
the way he says things and the way he
just just oh look just a little look
from him tells you so much about this
guy his history and everything else the
other thing that could have been a real
brick around the movies next is Nova the
young human girl that and again in terms
of the overall there is the thing that
was a cool thing to get layered in which
I wasn't expecting because you know
people have said you know this is
actually a prequel to the original 60s
Planet of the Apes and I kind of I've
always approached that adds all
philosophically that's a neat idea I
don't know how cleanly it's kind of slot
in but they have act I mean you have to
disregard the latter um sequels to that
film because they come up with their own
origin for how the age Scott smart and
everything else so you need to disregard
all that but if you're looking at just
that original with Charlton Heston in it
then yeah this is surprisingly lining up
with everything well and with Nova they
cover the idea of why humans in that
film in that future are mute and don't
speak which wasn't
me I was expecting to be a drug there
wasn't like a boy I hope they fill them
that flat hole but I love that they came
up with a way that felt organic to do it
and yet have recalled Nova which is a
wonderful nod to the original there were
a lot of very cool little nods know who
was one the the crosses that they hang
the I mean they're not really crosses
their exes but the the things that they
hang the Apes up were basically the same
ratings as the Scarecrow's from the
beginning of the Planet of the Apes
movie and there were just these great
wonderful visual or dialogue nods to the
original film because I do love the
original plan of the Apes I love it a
lot I don't want to compare it to these
because I think they're you know just
the style of filmmaking and acting and
everything else is very different this
movie really does a number of things
that I think under other circumstances
are in the hands of another filmmaker
could have sent the thing off the rails
I already mentioned the insertion of a
comic relief character another thing is
killing Caesar's son so like to make a
comparison pretty much my own writing I
this is why I have a hard time even
sitting down to give it another shot
problem with something like say alien 3
is that it opens with the death of Newt
now the reason that's a problem is that
it completely negates the entire climax
of aliens which is not only a better
film but the entire confrontation with
the alien queen in that film is sparked
by Ripley trying to save news so to open
the next film with and she died anyway
so all that was pointless really did it
always will rub me the wrong way and
that could have happened here with the
death of Caesar's oldest son but it
doesn't and I think it's because in this
case again comparing to alien 3 and I'm
sure there's other examples it's just my
go-to comparison but to compare it again
in alien 3 it was we are getting these
characters out we are dismissing them
because we don't want to use them which
feels disrespectful and just wasteful in
this film and war for the Planet of the
Apes the death of Caesar's son drives
the narrative
it drives Caesars decisions and what he
does so yes it is it possible that it's
negating some of what he achieved in
less oh yes but then there are immediate
to that and it drives his choices which
therefore drive the narrative so it is
respectful of the decision to kill off
the characters as opposed to just doing
as earlier dismissively which is what
alien 3 felt like I think the only like
one real notable criticism I feel I can
level against if that isn't a matter of
case because like you know the salmon
with Woody Harrelson that's kind of a
bit of a matter of taste
the thing about it not having us
strongest thread of hope that's a
personal taste I can't say that makes
the movie worse just makes it a little
bit less than my liking is I think it's
probably about 10 minutes that could
have stood to be cut out of act 2 you
know the period in which just the Apes
are captured and that whole section in
there I feel like there's about 10
minutes not like whole to be lifted but
just trimming down bits of that to
remove about ten minutes of it I think
would have streamlined it because it
felt like we spent a little bit too much
time there which I suppose you can argue
makes it all the more Toronto when they
get out of there he's like oh finally
they're out but for me it came closer I
didn't check my watch but I got
borderline just during that part but it
was brief if that that was a that was a
brief little how much longer are we
going to be in this place kind of thing
but it this movie is one of the best
trilogy conclusions in recent memory
that I can throw out there it's just it
is a wonderful conclusion to the
personal journey of Caesar as a
character it is a wonderful conclusion
for this trilogy of films completing an
arc setting up that original 60s film
this is just really great work and this
is another great film there have been Oh
surprising number of really good films
this summer usually put the summer I
expect to get one really good film at a
bunch of pretty good films yes that was
pretty good or that was fonder that was
this about with that we've had some
really good stuff and that's nice
that's always nice when it can happen so
that's pretty much my thoughts on war
for the plane of the 8 not perfect I
still think Dawn is a little bit better
but it's really really good and if you
are fan of this franchise assuming
that your expectations that not get put
out of whack by the marketing I think
you're going to be really really
satisfied with this conclusion to this
franchise so what are your thoughts on
it whatever they are drop something down
in the comment let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]